[Music]
wow fancy we're going into o'shea's
we actually went in there when we were
in vegas mike actually remember this
we're gonna eat late night [ __ ] yeah but
we weren't
acting like we were on a sexy date no we
were on acid
we were on acid and i also that was the
night i got so drunk
and took acid that i i ordered an entire
pizza and then left remember that we go
okay gotta get we gotta tell the story
now hold on a second we haven't never
told this story
so we're hanging out we're in vegas and
our friend miami moff happened to be
there for some sort of
old lady convention yeah it was a some
kind of i think they were just buffing
the floors
home so they were letting them all out
for a bit
[Laughter]
they're hanging out and that night we're
like hey let's take some acid
somebody gave us acid so we did mike
took a little bit more than me
a little bit more just a tiny bit mike
took a lot of acid
i took a respectable amount and we're
walking around
i mean it was like late right and we're
like hungry so we it might have been
o'shea's where we went to
right there where they just walked by so
we go in there and we're hanging out
and we're sitting down we're eating and
we're like oh we're hungry we're hungry
and we order our food mike orders an
entire pizza and i'm not talking about
like a little pizza here's an
entire pizza well to be fair it was one
of the personal pizzas right it was
still a whole pizza but whatever
he orders the pizza and then he sits
look at me was it
before after the who got there that you
left it was arriving and i was like
yes she's walking up with the food
marshmallows goes i have to go back to
the room
and the thing is i was also drunk on
acid but the problem wasn't it wasn't
that i was too on too much acid
and it wasn't that i was too drunk it
was the combination
and i was it was also i was just really
tired too
and and the [ __ ] the booze hit me
it's just the right and i'm like
i i gotta go i i gotta go and royce is
like
well [ __ ] grab a slice at least i'm
like yeah i don't even want it
and i just got up and went back and i
slept at the airport i was so out of it
that night
i took like three hits of acid just
wandered around that was nice so we're
sitting there and the food gets there
and then we're just i'm like what do we
do with this pizza
i've remember correctly i think i think
miami milf did you take the pizza home
somebody took it with them
i think i might have taken it with me in
a box and then i still didn't touch it
right i think i brought it back to the
airbnb and i was like they're like do
you want a box and i'm like
yeah i don't know i guess so and then i
just brought it back and i threw it on
the counter and i went to sleep
i was so out of it that night how was
that
[ __ ] it was fun night spent most of the
night staring at the senior frogs
yeah when we were walking down the strip
mike had taken so much when it finally
kicked
in uh we were hanging out with that
night with miami milfon
ag luck ag luck miami milf uh sicko was
there
sicko was there uh and then there was
that remember that was like that lesbian
broad and her friend
they was talking to us for a little bit
and then they left oh that lesbian chick
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah remember i
forget forget her name i feel bad now
but
uh oh that other miranda oh that other
girl yeah the [ __ ]
crazy one yeah and then we just [ __ ]
and then i just kept leaving because
oh and then the hooker remember the
hooker that kept talking to us that was
like oh okay so then all right so we're
hanging out oh this is a good story a.g
lux in here
that's why i kept leaving that wait i
think i know this part the reason i kept
leaving that night because everybody was
like oh i'm worried merch keeps leaving
and
royce was like he's fine trust me i've
seen him on drugs he's fine
but i had to keep leaving because this
hooker was so [ __ ] hilariously train
wrecky
she was sitting on hg well here's what
happened
i actually remember this mommy milk hop
into the green room real quick
quick if you want i started howling in
this girl's face laughing that's why i
had to keep leaving because the acid was
coming in i just got
right at her so in her tits and i'm
laughing at him we're hanging out at a
casino because it was dennis remember
correctly was like kind of dead that
night right
so we were hanging out i forget what
hotel we were hanging out at
so we're chilling in the we're just at
the casino hanging out
and this hooker all right caesar we're
all we're all sitting there
this hooker walks up obviously clearly a
hooker she's saying all the things that
a hooker says
and she was kind of chunky too i
remember [ __ ] mess
yeah she was not great and
she
first walks up to me answers like so
where are you from
dad where are you from i'm like i'm busy
i'm
clearly a hooker then she walks up to
marsh and at this point like
merc just started tripping like the
asset was just kicking off
i was already tripping this is when i
started really peaking and i was like oh
boy buddy this is where the ride starts
so and i just started laughing in her
face right right right so she
uncontrollably
yeah i was like i can't do this and i
had to leave
uh miami well for the patreon discord
get into the green room so
that happens right then mike leaves
because he's looking for anything to do
mike walks around to a
my uh okay i'm gonna pull her in there
she did it okay i'm and then we'll
uh i went outside miami milford mute
yourself or do we have to mute her we
have to do it
i got her mommy milf you there
yeah hey okay so tell me remind me if
i'm telling this story correctly okay
so then merch starts giggling yes he
starts tripping go ahead
go ahead what happened next no so yeah i
caught her eye at the bar and i'm like
okay
is that a woman of the night what is
happening here and
um she came over i guess and then i
immediately said no no i'm with this guy
and we're together and so we all tried
to
pon her off on a.g that's where it got
really
fun that's when it got crazy so aj's by
himself ordering a drink and we go look
we're not interested
sorry we're not interested but i i said
oh we lied i might even if you and i
lied and you said oh yeah we're married
no there's no thank you
and yeah and then i go oh you're just so
lovely i just saw you at the bar
yes that's because she was oh my god she
was hitting a miami milf too i just
remembered
okay you're right so then we see that so
then we bought her off my day poor ag
luck is sitting there
with this drink by the way being nothing
but a nice guy
she walks up and she sits down and she
and i go but you know who would be
interested
we go that guy over there with buddy
over there anthony so
she walks over there and she sits down
and we could
we're howling at our own table going
like oh my god
because the look on his face was like
what's happening
then she goes here's my room number i'm
staying here
she's not obviously but they tell them
that my room number but then she said
but i got it no wait okay go ahead what
no no you're about to say phone number
yes go ahead go ahead this one again
she's like oh but here i got to give you
was it my kid's phone number
my daughter's got that that's right
because my phone's not working i have to
give you my
daughter's phone by the way we're
talking the daughter was like 10. yeah
i gotta give you my daughter's phone
because
mine's not working text me here
she was using her daughter's phone for
hooker
oh work prostitute work i had to get up
and leave
three or four times because i just kept
like were you there when she flashed her
tits i don't know i was there when i
said
i couldn't miss them you could see it
from the [ __ ] bellagio that was
no that was the second time i got up and
left because
the first time i started laughing
because we were all kind of giggling
but then when she came up she talked to
them first then she started talking to
me
and i just uncontrollably was laughing
in her face
and it was like really insulting to her
which made everybody else more
uncomfortable
and i couldn't once i started i couldn't
stop laughing and i was like
i said i was thinking of something
tonight from yesterday i gotta go
and i just got up because i had weed
from the dispensaries i was like i'm out
of here yeah so i went outside to smoke
and calm down
so aj luck has a cocktail napkin i
remember him opening up he goes
she gave me her daughter's phone number
what is going on
and then like i come back i calm down
i'm breathing right we're all kind of
having a little giggle but everybody's
calming down
but i can't stop the giggles and then
her titty popped out
and i was [ __ ] not a pop
how i was belly laughing from my
soul her tits literally i'm not saying
literally right this time because you
saw him
they spilled onto they literally yeah
they spilled onto the table they just
the
winning different directions yes they
were [ __ ] cockeyed
and they just went it looked like
it looked like the kind of titty job
that david bond would pay for
oh my god it was so [ __ ] bad
and we just kept poor ag luck was by but
dude was minding his own business
he was just chilling there he's he was
sitting there he was chilling there on
his phone he was like
and then she just sits down and she's
like sorry i heard
i she was hammered too sorry i heard she
likes to party
yeah and i'm like dude and i was i was
getting to the point where it felt like
i'd been doing crunches
because i'd laughed so much and then i
come back a second time and i'm sitting
there and that's when she starts getting
on ag luck or whatever
and then the third time was when she
brought up that it was her daughter's
phone
and then described like the age of the
daughter and i was
[ __ ] dying laughing again i was like
i i gotta leave again i'm so sorry i
gotta leave
and every time i would get up to leave i
would be screaming laughing and royce
would keep going where are you going oh
yes
that's right no he's in it i don't know
he's interested in you i think he's just
got something i don't know what's going
on with him
i'm keeping my cool and marsha's walking
away and
me and miami milf were like marsh where
are you going
oh god bart she's cool bro come back and
she was
she was night and day from our waitress
too remember the waitress oh yeah
who was like gorgeous beautiful she was
beautiful we were like damn and then
this hooker came over and it was like oh
and she was just she looked like that
crazy that weird body modification chick
that we played yesterday
and and and then then all i remember
this and look much credit to a.g look
i'll give him this as soon as she walked
away
i saw him crumble it up
and just throw the number in the garbage
he's like [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] both of you [ __ ] off i even think
they gave
i think he gave her a fake number and if
he did he did he did give her a fake
number he's like yeah i just gave her
that was the hardest i'd laughed in a
long time was right in that woman's face
oh my god and it was mostly the acid
making me laugh but it was still just
like
no no it was it was hurt too hilarious
but it was also the acid just
boom just hit me like a [ __ ] brick
wall so i was like
like right in her face and everybody's
like jesus dude and i'm like i
can't yeah excuse me excuse me
was twice was like i gotta go to the
bathroom again and i go you just
mercy you just went you don't need to go
again i said i had to go to the bathroom
three and you know like when you're on
lsd your sense of time is also
completely skewed
so i thought that in the course of an
hour i'd said three times i need to go
to the bathroom
but all of this happened in the span of
about 15 minutes it wasn't
wrong so i got up to use the bathroom
three times in 15 minutes but all three
times
just dying laughing cats like i can't do
this i can't do it when the titties came
out
i was [ __ ] done bro i couldn't move
they were [ __ ] terrible
we got to go to vegas again it was vegas
was super fun it was
super fun uh i'm ready yeah that's good
[ __ ] it let's do it again let's do it
again
it was [ __ ] great that was one of the
funniest things what kind of hotel like
what kind of aarp
like hotel deals do you get oh she could
say it's circus circus
exactly yeah you nailed it circus circus
i'll take the christmas
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] anything anything
on fremont street i got you
she was staying at one of the nicer
hotels actually i remember i'm sitting
in the baller hotel
and i'm like [ __ ] you you're just a win
and we're like this is beautiful no and
it wasn't even that she was staying at
the weight because look i hate miami
i'd love to [ __ ] bury my fist in her
stomach sometimes but
it's not that she was staying at the
wind it was it was how she
kept saying she was staying oh my god
bougie that i wanted
i literally wanted to throat chopper at
one point at one point
we started the night at the bar there
it's like come come gentlemen and hang
out here with me and
so this bar is beautiful the drinks are
like 20 bucks a pop
we're like yeah we got to get a [ __ ]
cab back to the airbnb she's like oh
i'm at the window i'm at the win shut
the [ __ ] up i just need to go i just
need to go upstairs
yeah that's all it's all covered it's
all paid for i'm like i'll [ __ ] kill
you [ __ ] hate it was that that's true
that was that's
[ __ ] that's for real though i hate
you that [ __ ] vegas trip was one of
the most fun things man that was [ __ ]
great
i remember i had to take a [ __ ] at one
point on acid at the palazzo and it's
like all marble there
and it's like the patterns and the
patterns on marble
are very disturbing when you're on
traffic and especially when you're boxed
into a bathroom stall
and i thought that i was in um was that
thing from star wars where it's like
the big giant trash compactor i felt
like i was stuck in that
the sarlacc pit i felt like i was stuck
in there and i'm like i'm going to die
that was a fun game god damn it man that
was great
good times i know we have to let you go
because they have the early bird special
the golden corral you got to get the cut
off it's
oh it's almost bedtime yeah i got it i
gotta go it's almost
6 30 is the cut off at country time
buffet oh
[ __ ] thank you for being on you're the
first person we've had on the page
rancho thank you miami milf
all right let's beat it that's a nice
trip down but see that's how you do
pickup artistry guys
god damn that was hilarious just go to
vegas eat a bunch of acid and just be we
got to go again
it was so much it was so much fun it was
a good trip
[ __ ] some people in the chat my milf
sounds hot relax
no she is hot she's just all so old
don't tell her that but she's also older
she's got it
you know what i mean you give him a
little a compliment sandwich rice
you know what i mean well in her place
would be a compliment oatmeal but i hear
what you're saying
compliment sandwich but can i get
lettuce for bread
a compliment lettuce wrap